uh and we're going to do a minute a
speaker given the fact that we have so
many speakers and I want to make sure we
get to every single
speakers good evening there seems to be
some confusion as to why 4547 Park Place
should be granted Landmark status Mayor
Bloomberg and the city council have for
reasons unknown failed to back up their
decision to demolish this building
further many in the media failed to
report the reasons why this building
should or should not be landmarked for
example today in the New York Times
Clyde hammerman's column titled Islamic
Center fight lessons and prepositions
and fear Ming what is he talking about
never once does he mention the historic
value of 4 4547 Park Place rather he
chooses to accuse conservatives of
making statements that are inflammatory
or misleading or both poor Mr Haberman
he doesn't understand this is not a
political issue in the words of Bob tyy
chairperson of the LPC 31 Broadway was
granted Landmark status since since it's
one of the few remaining pazo style
buildings in lowermanhattan yes both 311
Broadway and 45 Park Place are Italian
Renaissance pazo style buildings in
light of the fact that these buildings
are scar why was one granted Landmark
status and the other is about to be
denied that status the historical
significance of this property is clear
completed in 1857 through
1858 this five story store and LOF
building is a fine example of the
Italian Renaissance inspired pazi that
flourished from the 1850s through the
1870s by drawing upon architectural
vocabulary of the Italian Renaissance
plazos the Builders of pal structures
like 4547 Park Place sought to project
an image of prestige and economic power
this building Still Remains much of its
historic fabric including its original
ground floor carian colay okay I I need
to ask W
up thank
you it's now my great pleasure to
introduce a great friend of Laura
Manhattan Senator Daniel Squadron who
has done an out standing job
representing our Lower Manhattan
Community and
so thrill that he's here before going up
to ALB so we're really excited that he's
here with us tonight yes I'm very
excited to be going up to Albany let me
tell you uh I had no idea my retail
report was so popular there's a line up
the door so it's pretty ex uh and I what
I what I've said about that uh I've said
it before uh is I don't think there is
any communities uh that should have any
any other community I don't there's any
neighborhood that should have any
Community prohibited from being there uh
I think that especially in lower
Manhattan the
idea you can Bo me when I'm done I think
that especially in lower Manhattan which
is the community that I represent uh we
are uh welcoming we are diverse and
certainly there are no no areas that
don't accept religions for cultures
anywhere in country
Julie I know you were hoping that I
would take a
question okay any other one or two more
questions for the
senator hand up
first ma'am you are out of order if you
continue this you're going to have to
leave the
meeting okay is there another is there
another question for the senator
yes sure I'm concerned as to why no one
is considering the value of this
building as a historic building no one
will talk about the landmark
preservation issu I'm not here about
anything else other than discuss why
this building should be landar so but
why won't you why do you say why do we
always have to bring in religion and
everything else don't you fight for
buildings in New York City with restor
value to be preserved quot fair enough
and to respect out of respect for the
community board this is going to be the
last question I take on this topic
uh I Absol absolutely and I think that
it's up to Landmark preservation
commission I don't have much an
aesthetic eye sometimes I like
architecture sometimes they don't but I
got to tell you that decision has to be
about the building itself and not about
the proposed use one way or the other
and I think that that's an absolutely
legitimate question on any building
unrelated to its use on topics other
than this okay so I warn you about that
I o feel in particular about this mosque
this is a mosque that wants to use
sacred ground to be built on sacred
ground this is where 3,000 lives were
lost I don't see how this community
board and the mayor can even can even
consider such a thing I just want I want
to give you the history of what Islam
does with I'm going to ask you to sit
down it's been a
minute she had her minute everyone has a
minute you all have the same amount of
time the next speaker is Barbara Puchi
followed by
Jen check the history of Islam and holy
[Applause]
places hello my name is
barar I wanted to say tonight I I
testified at the lmar preservation
commission's hearing I submitted a
formal request for a 911 historic
district to be created I just handed the
uh chairman of this committee a copy of
my statement to them listing all the
architectural reasons to Landmark the
building as well as a copy of the
request for the landmark uh historic
district to be created which would
include
4-47 uh Park Place
so if nothing else we deserve a historic
district of that event now I would like
to ask either p b or Robert Spen to come
up and address this which is a copy of
an email I have today that talks about
the Imam this Imam Ralph who says one
thing in English and something else
quite different in Arabic would you
please come up and address this please
take my time thank you the next speaker
is y hland followed by
Joyce everyone gets one minute so when
one minute is expired no one
gets right now we're over capacity
you've got 30 people out here who aren't
even going to be able to speak because
this room is over capacity
please
speak our next speaker is Joyce Boland
followed by Eileen
dun scand and I live in Ringwood New
Jersey and uh I have a son who was 25 he
was on the 97th floor of to one and the
plane hit directly into where he was
working that morning um I consider
myself one of the lucky ones if I can
say lucky because most families did not
get back any remains however we did get
back 2 in of skin 3 in of attendant and
a couple of pieces of bone so you can
see that ground zero to me is the burial
site of my son it is a very very special
place it it's like a cemetery where you
go to visit your family
um excuse
me time I don't want to have to go when
I go down to visit my son and see
and pray and talk to him to look up and
to see a MK overwhelming looking down at
me that's
right son every day that he's there his
remains are in that dirt that when the
bells ring to call the people to prayer
he has to hear those bells and know why
he's there and not home with me it's a
call it's
this is a s well maybe it is but a duck
By Any Other Name is still a
duck when you when they want to extend a
hand of friendship you don't extend a
hand of friendship by putting out one
hand here and the other hand with a
knife that's going into your heart and
killing you
right I want to know where the money is
coming from for this MTH I would like a
full
investigation of where this money comes
from and that it's not blood money and
if it isn't blood money and they still
collect the money then if they really
want to be friends what they should do
is take that money don't build the
mosque there they bu anywhere else ma'am
your time is Don't Cut Her
Off our next speaker is iene Jon Follow
by
and let me just say one thing to the
woman who spoke before that I just on
behalf of the board we certainly extend
our condolences to you for your
love June HSE followed by
Bruce I'm here to speak about Emma and
Katie their father work for k m Jo on
the floor of the World Trade Center he
died on September 11
2001 his remains were never
found Emma and Katie were only 5 and 2
years old at the time the World Trade
Center Memorial will be the only grave s
they will ever
have there may have been very good
intentions for this young Islamic man to
build a m near the World Trade Center to
attempt to foster a better understanding
of Islam unfortunately
Emma and Katie and the many many other
children relatives and friends who lost
loved ones that day should not have this
place of mourn and Sorrow overshadowed
by a large imposing Islamic mosque it is
not only inappropriate it is unfairly
asking too much of all of these people
this young man who wants to do something
special for Islam I think I can make a
suggestion to him he could donate any
money he has collected and use it to
fight the extremists within
Islam there are mod muss in this country
in this country and I'm sure elsewhere
that are actually afraid of speaking out
against this Islamic extremist group
because they themselves are
attacked the greatest gift yes in
Illinois the greatest gift this young
man could give everyone is if he could
use the money he has collected to help
protect these mod Muslims who do speak
out and hopefully try in every way
possible to re-educate these Islamic
extremists and that
air followed by
vumar in May at this uh meeting in May
that we had um I was uh sort of attacked
as I was leaving by people who said that
I um didn't know history so I I just
want to put out a challenge that if
anyone here lived through 9/11 as I did
and who suffered any kind of loss as a
result of the Holocaust and has been to
yasham in Israel I would cord challenge
them to a debate on history and the
meaning of repression I'm serious if
anyone would like to join me in that
debate I would love to engage you on a
serious level not on a shouting
screaming level I've been inculcated in
this matter my entire life so please
someone who can meet those criteria
please take me up on the challenge now I
want to read to the extent that I have
time a piece from um from uh Steven
prero who is a professor of religion an
author of uh Many religious books writes
for the Washington Post and also
CNN uh he writes that um and this was
recently um if Sharif elgamal who is one
of the principles in this matter
continues to receive opposition to this
project on religious grounds as he did
on July 13th at a lar preservation
commission hearing from groups such as
to stop islamicization of America he
will have a slam dunk case under
powerful legislation pushed into law
ironically by many of these same people
on the religious right now oppose so
adamant to this community center and
mosque okay I got to ask you to wrap up
are we done yeah okay okay I'll read one
more sentence the religious land use and
institutionalized persons Act is a
federal statute enacted in 2000 by
unanimous consent in both the house and
the Senate it's purpose to safeguard the
religious Liberties of Americans
including groups whose places of worship
are Under Fire
okay vumar followed by my name is vard
Kumar in real State there are three most
important
factors the three are location location
location why do they want to build a
mosque on this particular
place there is is a long background to
this why why this is the problem is not
the mass problem is the
location the Pagan Pantheon of Caba
located in Mecca was the first
non-muslim Sanctuary to be used as a
mosque this was done by Prophet Muhammad
himself after he conquered Makkah in 630
C since then it has been established
practice of Muslim conquerors to
demolish icons the people the conquer
and build a mask to use the iconic
structure of the EV
mask let me give a few
examples AOS is Jerusalem is at a site
also known as the so you need to wrap up
please okay so okay let me wrap it up
very shortly you need to wrap up right
now got
another please finish everyone gets
exact same amount of time
please finish your sentence very in the
medeval time churches and synagogue and
Temple used to be the icons of
civilizations today these icons have
been reped by democracy military and
economic might that is what America
stands for today building a mosque at
the HED grounds of demolish WTC
i s you finish a sentence we we need to
move on there are 30 people out there
who are aren't even going to be able to
speak it's absolutely not fair that
everyone doesn't get equal time our next
speaker is assembly member Glick Follow
by sa SAA desari followed by Denise lefo
yeah hi my name is SATA desari I'm from
Hindu Human Rights Watch we are also a
member of Coalition for human rights
organization where moderate Muslims are
also part of it I just want to uh
request you to preserve that side where
the mosque is going to be built not only
because for what it is if it is not
preserved what is expected to be piled
and for some of you who are uh for my
dear Senator and other people the board
who are telling us that we should have
tolerance I want to ask you have you
asked the questions with Mr ra or other
people how come you WR where are you
getting the funding from what is that
you wrote In the book how come you have
been so many things are told to us and
you are not asking those questions to
this you become covers of our own
thinking
and I tell you we suffered so much 0
million of us were pictured today
350,000 of us were killed and every me
one Islamic country except turkey where
there is tolerance they are not hiding
the fact Jihad is whether is a wward
Jihad or a stealth Jad it is still the
same and it can cause the same damage
this is a great country find out open up
your eyes see
what thank you very
much hi I'm I'm Luke Kamali an average
everyday Citizen and the conscience of
the United
States I want to tell
you that the Imam who's behind this this
mosque has ties to the offshoots of
Muslim Brotherhood read his book you'll
find out he has ties to the recent
flotilla incident over Gaza why why is
he involved at all he has told the US
that we were responsible for
I don't believe that he has insisted
that the US needs to understand the mind
of the terrorist I don't want to
understand the mind of the
terrorist in Staten Island just recently
there was a Catholic Church that was
going to sell a Convent to Muslims that
were connected to Muslim Brotherhood
they once they found out that there was
a terrorist ties they declined the fail
wo and I am appealing to this committee
please find out the background of this
Imam before it is too late find out what
he stands for don't be fooled do your
homework one last comment excuse me I'm
sorry your time is up one last comment
we just can't put a memorial to the
ideology that killed innocent people
right at the foot of their brain
John yes inent that's great if you could
go okay I I think there are so many
non-racist non bigoted non insensitive
reasons not to build this MOS um and in
addition there are so many warning signs
and flags a lot of them will mention
today like I think one gentleman tried
to say that uh the Cordova project which
is the name of this they chose that name
and if you look back I think in 14th
century Muslims conqu Cordova in Spain
uh where is the money coming from and
that's what I want to ask the senator
that was standing up here earlier uh
whose Goodwills and intentions said that
you should be able to build in any
Community do they know the facts do they
know all these uh uh warning signs and
flags that are going on with this
project but I think the real reasons is
when you listen to the mother that lost
her son as well as the other lady who
spoke about the two little children
those are reasons enough not to build
this
moner in addition I think
that those people that are backing this
can do more by way of healing and Peace
by saying we understand you we heard you
we will not build here thank
you hi my name is John press Dr John
press I am the President of the Brooklyn
tea party and the author of the book
culturism um people have been saying
that what we're saying is racist because
they're multiculturalist they say all
cultures are the same and to say
anything otherwise is is racist this is
wrong cultural diversity is Real Islam
has been hostile to us hostile to the
west from the beginning read your
history Muhammad and Jesus very
different
characters obviously somebody said we're
we're not going to have uh we have laws
that are going to prevent this we need
to have culturist laws Saudi Arabia
doesn't let us build churches they're
culturist we also need to be trusted and
it can start here the name of this
project is the Cordova House why because
Islam has taken the west and they want
to celebrate their ability to push us
and maybe take us again we need to have
some culturist awareness people it's not
racist to point out the cultural
diversity is real it's culturist we got
to get rid of us celebrate diversity of
cultural of multiculturalism and and
instead have a culturist mindset and
have culturism thank you
hi I'm Joy Brighton a New Yorker I'm
appealing to everyone who usually
watches 6 minutes but didn't watch it on
Sunday on Sunday lesie stall interviewed
a guy by the name of Maj namz who was a
British guy Regular Guy brought up in a
non-religious household who was then
radicalized went into a terror group
around 27 countries called hisb terer
and decided that he wanted to enforce
the strict interpretation of Islam onto
everyone as he'd been told that was
important to do no religious freedom
which is I know something we all care
about religious freedom he has since
reversed course and he now works with
the British government to say we need to
stop the radicalization of Youth but how
do we do it there's a narrative going on
out there and the narrative says that
America is at war with Islam not true he
says there's MOS everywhere in America
there's a narrative that's going on that
says America's at war with Iraq to kill
Muslims not Jews about oil oil oil now
how do we stop the narrative and he said
it's so hard because what we're dealing
with is a political movement not a
religion anymore it's more political
movement and the way to stop it is to
stop the narrative but the narrative is
being told on all kinds of streets a lot
of people aren't even going to have time
to speak we have to all the time thank
you one second pleas The Narrative is
being told on city streets and in MOS
some M through political basis some M
through religious basis way fundraising
and the affiliation of the leaders it's
a known fact
differentiated um Dr s Sanson Frontline
fighter on Islam Christianity and Jews
related
issues I will just say for the future
reference that this mask will be the
slogan from Islam that we have defeated
America number
two from Quran Surah 5: 51
5:51 it says do not be friendly to Jews
and
Christians bukari Vol 7 Hadith number
5892 and
199 and volume 4 number
3462 do the opposite of Jews and
Christians that is from Islam so if any
Muslim wants the mutual respect they
should allow
all the Jews and Christians to pay and
churches in front
of we have Follow
by Follow by
je hi uh my name is sh FAL and I am here
as a resource regarding the landmarks
issue in respect to 45 Park Place thank
you very
much our next speaker